bandwidth for Mac break is brought to
you by cash fly at CAC a GF ly calm
hey I'm Justine with iJustine calm and
we are here at macworld 2009 at the best
booth ever if you guys know me you know
I am obsessed with iPhone applications
and here is the best iphone application
ever it is the ocarina you notice he's
playing an inch it's an instrument
that's basically what it is the US have
other apps to besides the ocarina do yes
we have five apps right now we just came
out with one called zephyr which is the
wind as we like to say it it's like a
message in a bottle you can write little
messages and send them around the world
and then people all over the world can
read the messages that you've written in
the snow in the winds crazy and that's
what's most awesome is that is that that
proper most awesome I don't know but let
me tell you that's how I explain smule
I'll because all of your applications
they work together kind of with everyone
online so you be on your iPhone and I
can be listening to people playing
around the world they're amazing ocarina
songs that's one one of the main aspects
of smell is the sort of social component
to our applications all of our
applications have this little globe view
you can kind of see here I don't know if
you get that on the on the video but
yeah this globe you can pop up and you
can see and hear other people around the
world the network's totally crashed
right here but yeah normally you can see
and hear other people playing around the
world and that's one of the great things
about our applications it's amazing and
when the app oh oh here I hear it uh-oh
someone playing in uh and it's amazing
to see because when this app was first
released no one was playing songs they
were just playing these terrible little
tunes and then now people are playing
completely full songs and you guys have
tabs and stuff cheap it's like sheet
music right we got a lots of sheet music
here's an example right here here's a
this amazing grace and you can get these
on our website at smule com or ocarina
smule com all right you know what let's
let's play a song for everybody you want
to do that all right what should we play
any some sheet music though you know
what do we got amazing
grace let's do it you want to do this
yeah okay alright guys welcome to the
ocarina yeah for the iphone a domain
ready yeah okay
righto there gotta do it yes that is the
ocarina by smeal the best iphone
application ever I screwed it up I'm the
mule I should be able to play this stuff
but I Justine right here rocks the rock
arena how much how much even since 99
cents you can have all this fun at any
point in time you can be super
expressive and super musical you don't
even have to know to play musical
instrument because you can go on our
website and read the tabs just like we
did super easy five year olds have been
learning here today how to play in about
two minutes I've actually I've actually
never even played that song before that
was my first time there you go bona fide
example right there oh and one of the
things you yes we have questions from
the audience is it work with the first
generate it does it works on all iphones
on mm-hmm yeah that yes you just blow
inside the microphone so in it acts just
like an instrument it's amazing isn't it
what hold on what do you think we've got
we've got the crowd here what do you
think of this app no this is absolutely
terrific this is the kind of thing that
is new unique anybody can just pick it
up and play and and I have fun with it I
know it is so much fun and I love the
interactive of the world it's amazed at
is really cool it is i love that that
concept that like i have friends all
over the world and we're playing music
and it's no i love it it is great and I
carry my iphone everywhere so like I
have my instrument wherever I am I have
to excuse me I have to go bye look I
have to go download okay [ __ ] good luck
by two or more we'll give you a free
t-shirt oh man this is the most exciting
day of my life you want to get yours I
got one yeah you got yours right alright
guys that is the ocarina by smule get it
now 99 cents
you